[Music]
simba you have to take your place as
king beyonce bringing the animated
classic to life almost gives you chills
doesn't it just hearing her do it it's
been like mantises it's really it's a
really special thing singing alongside
Simba queen bees embraced her role as
the grown-up Nala
but it's the look of this almost frame
for frame live-action remake that might
end up being the main attraction here
just ask one of the hyenas aka
keegan-michael key the photo-realistic
treatment they've given to it is amazing
it's more dangerous more grave more
funny and more Beyonce more and more
Beyonce's thing's gonna make us petrolia
dollars this reboot hits theatres next
month but you got to love Disney's
timing cuz today marks the 25th
anniversary of the original film's
premiere back then Matthew Broderick
told us why he was only Simba's speaking
voice and didn't sing in the movie I
recorded it twice but then they they
elected not to use my recordings
for the rest of your days but it's very
like pop kind of singing that I didn't
quite pull off I guess this time around
Donald gets to do both but it won't
score this dad of to any points at home
they're just like yeah like whatever
like even you can be like whatever like
he doesn't really it doesn't affect say
anything yet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]